so if you keep sending people on suicide
missions and they come back alive does
that mean they're really good or really
bad
[Applause]
[Music]
all right I've been meaning to try and
catch up on the last couple of DC
animated films that have come out and I
have now arrived at Suicide Squad held
to pay
I was nervous coming into this but for a
different reason than usual if you've
been following my coverage of these DC
animated films you know that I
frequently go in nervous because the
consistency of these things has been
shot to absolute hell of late they went
they had a really long really solid
stretch for a long time but then once
they started doing new 52 material with
Justice League war he got really uneven
every now and then we'd have something
great or you know we had the various
really good if not flat-out brilliant
like Justice League dark or like gods
and monsters or at least something that
was a heck of a lot of fun like Batman
assault on Arkham glass and we got
Suicide Squad other times we would just
get other slugs that were just painful
you know things like sort of Atlantis or
Teen Titans versus Justice League or
things that were just weird like in bad
ways like The Killing Joke and Batman
and Harley Quinn so I did I had no idea
what this was gonna be like I did know
that it is not in continuity with Batman
assault on Arkham and I did know that it
did not have the same writer that said
the writer that they did have on it Alan
Burnett has been involved in the DC
Animated stuff pretty much from the
beginning and has written most of the
best stuff you know things like gods and
monsters the the story credit goes to
Bruce Timm but the actual writer of the
script was Alan Burnett and he wrote the
script for return of the Joker and for
mask of the phantasm
like the only one that he wrote that
wasn't any good was tight Teen Titans vs
Justice League and he produced a lot of
them crap ones but for his writing has
been really solid but you know knowing
how much I liked the last Arkham Asylum
I said yep assault on Arkham which was
blast Suicide Squad one eye I was I was
nervous that it just it wasn't gonna
live up to that but I did pretty well
this this was this was what I wanted it
to be which I don't get to say as often
as I would like to when it comes to the
DC anime stuff because this is just fun
ridiculous over the top violent fun and
this is all this is all loaded cast to I
mean in terms of the characters the
voice actors not a ton of recognizable
feed features you know you've got Tara
Strong back doing a Harley Quinn she's
kind of default at this point we've got
Christian Slater's Deadshot which is
kind of interesting
we've got Vanessa Williams doing Amanda
Waller and she does a good job I still
prefer CCH pounder who did her for
assault on Arkham and they also went
with a skinny version of Waller which I
just I just don't like I I love the I
love the wall I love that but they
didn't manage but like I'm getting into
nitpicks already though is it stop man
stop focus on the good stuff
so a little bit of a synopsis I I may
not have to get into spoilers talking
about this we'll see if I need to go
there or not but as I said this is not
in continuity with assault on Arkham so
pretty much starting clean on the
Suicide Squad concept without a ton of
exposition to draw it starts us in the
middle of a Suicide Squad mission that
goes I was gonna say badly doesn't go
badly goes basically going to blame but
it goes messy and then we follow the
latest assemblage of the Suicide Squad
as they go off and are sent by Amanda
Waller to attain an item which I will
explain what that is in a little bit
that might be considered a minor spoiler
because it doesn't get revealed what it
is they're actually after till
little bit into it but it's not that far
into it it's kind of the main plot
driving MacGuffin of the whole thing so
she has symbols a team we've got
Deadshot let's see if I remember
everybody Harley Quinn killer frost
Copperhead Captain Boomerang bronze
tiger I think that was everyone who's on
the - was officially on the team whole
bunch of other characters show up though
so basically we have the primary
highlights from the last time we had
Suicide Squad animated form that being
Deadshot Harley killer frost Captain
Boomerang and then basically some swap
outs
we've got Copperhead for our inhuman
looking muscle basically replacing king
shark and we've got bronze tiger as our
martial artist with a not entirely
lawful moral moral code standing in for
black tarantula from last time so they
have assembled an incredibly similar
team to what they had last time that
said what they've got them doing way
wilder in terms of what's going on
overall because assault on Arkham was
well it was what it sounded like they
were trying to break into this place and
yes there were a lot of you know people
crazy powers in Arkham but they were
just kind of there on the sidelines the
squad didn't actually have to go up
against all that many people who had
serious powers here they do a lot more
about bouncing different power sets off
each other both internally within the
group and with who they have to face and
you know with some of the disposable
characters we get early on and and some
of the the villains lost eight villains
basically everyone's a villain by some
definition and this thing but they play
a lot more with having interesting
powers and having them go up against
each other in interesting ways in the
action scenes which means the action
scenes are good because when the action
scenes in these animated movies are
painful for me it's basically when they
strip out the powers and go super
realistic like I hate the fight scene
between Batman and Robin in Batman
versus Robin because it's just them
throwing punches and it's so boring in
animation when you can do anything if
you're gonna give me a fight in a
superhero NME animation
I want what this gives me I want you
know speedsters being made to slip on
ice and you know and this guy with a
snake tail using it to wrap around
somebody and stop them from firing a gun
I want craziness and this gives me
craziness which is a lot of fun now I
mentioned two speeds just so I'll
mention some of the other characters who
show up I don't want to say where they
fit into this but there's a lot going on
we get a version of dr. fate
I don't know these like a version they
made up for this or if he's in fact from
the comics cuz I'm not familiar with
this particular version of dr. fate but
he was really interesting and he was
kind of fun we got just the right dose
am I mentioned a speedster we have
professor zoom show up we have silver
siren blockbuster Vandal Savage scandal
Savage that's his daughter in case you
didn't know God trying to think who was
punching Julie
captain vertigo huh boy
I think Black Manta yeah this thing is
packed and it's it's pretty fun pretty
much everybody works too it's really
solid across the board I'm not the only
one that didn't quite work for me was
Vandal Savage and because he's kind of
he's kind of talked up a bit at the
front end and I think this is one of the
less interesting and dynamic versions of
Vandal Savage that I've seen recently
and also admittedly I might be slightly
burned out on the character I feel like
I've gotten a lot of him in the last
decade or so you know he was semi
recurring on the Justice League cartoon
he you know he showed up in two
different TV shows he was in legends of
tomorrow he was a mono was Ra's al Ghul
in Gotham but I also feel like they've
been playing rasa that that version of
Ra's al Ghul was practically Vandal
Savage so my apologies for almost making
that mistake but I Vandal Savage right
now and that type of villain him
specifically in that type so I'll lump
Ra's al Ghul in there because he's been
overplayed too and they are and they are
similar in a lot of ways especially just
in terms of the execution we beginning
in non comics media lately I'm just kind
of burned out on the guy but he doesn't
drag the thing down thankfully Oh
professor Pig there's another one we see
I'm just gonna keep thinking of other
folks that who we see and like do a lot
not just like oh we see them know like
they do something in the story and
two-face shows up in a and a cool little
scene yeah
so much stuff going on here I like it
and the the main MacGuffin so now I'm
gonna get to what I would consider it be
semi spoiler because like I said it's a
little bit into the film so the main
thing that they are after is and they
find out about this thing from the
doctor from the version of dr. fate
that's in this is there was a card with
mystical supernatural powers and it says
on it get out of hell free and
supposedly it will do exactly that if
you die while holding this card you will
bypass judgment you won't go to hell you
will go straight to heaven no matter who
you were no matter what you did but it's
one-time use once it sends somebody up
cards useless has no power after that
cannot be used more than once so you can
imagine there's a lot of people who want
their hands on this and it's also the
perfect kind of mission for the suicides
Rob because it's the kind of thing to
send them after that's going to
encourage distrust and backstabbing
because the Suicide Squad you know
they're in it for a reduced sentence you
know time to get out of prison faster
but when you offer them something like
that if they believe that it's real
that's the kind of thing you would go
against someone who might potentially
you have the power to blow your head up
for because you know you get your hands
on that well what's she gonna do blow my
head up because then the things
spreading I go to heaven haha so it's a
good MacGuffin for the Suicide Squad
because it's it I mean this is a you
know a team that doesn't always function
very it's a dysfunctional team
frequently anyways and to throw in that
kind of thing that makes it very
believable that really anybody would be
going who
I could just take that over it and so
that really works sometimes I see these
sorts of things that and the way that
they strain the the team sometimes comes
across as contrived it feels properly
set up into the narrative and though and
the primary MacGuffin in this one so
that's nicely done
I think hardly was probably my favorite
character because and I say that
actually we get lighter doses of her
here then I then I think we did in
assault on Arkham and then we tend to in
general generally wouldn't hardly shows
up she shows up a lot but she's used in
light doses mainly as comic relief here
I think that's probably in large part
because there is more focus on the
people with actual superpowers so she is
just more she's there for the jokes and
she's good for the jokes like you've got
you've got characters like okay we're
gonna go around back you sneak through
and when I give the signal then she just
charges in with the back like that's
perfect that's Harley I love it
so it's yeah this is just fun I don't
know if I like this or assault on Arkham
better I probably have two back-to-back
them they're both right up there and
they both hit the right kind of fun they
are the same kind of raucous crazy wild
over-the-top fun I think I am of the
mind that I do think the sexualization
of certain characters in certain scenes
is unnecessary because I mean let's be
blunt about they're not gonna show
actual nudity because even when they
allow these things to go are it's only
for the violence and they're not gonna
do true and proper nudity so to have you
know hookers draped over Tobias whale
there's another character who shows up
and you know to have a character who
appears effectively naked we don't see
it's it's just in an odd way it feels
more gratuitous when it's not allowed to
just be completely gratuitous if that
makes any sense it's like you you can't
even go the distance with it so it seems
even more
than it would otherwise and it is kind
of pointless otherwise this pointless
titillation otherwise but it's it's
titillation that doesn't even go the
distance so I don't understand why they
include this stuff in things like this
so the assault on Arkham had it - it's
one of the scenes that makes me kind of
cringe from that one day there's a scene
with killer frost where you almost see
you're naked and safety you didn't need
that that was that was unnecessary and
that sort of thing I think it's in there
for the maturity now I do criticize you
know these DC animated films and you
know films in general for being mature
in the most superficial ways possible
ie blood and guts and nudity and
swearing like that's not mature that's
honestly that's super juvenile it's just
the it's a brand of juvenile we prefer
not to allow juvenile people you know
people who are in fact you vanaya to see
but it's still juvenile stuff but I'd
let it go a little bit more in something
like Suicide Squad held to pay because
that's kind of the vibe of the whole
thing it's it's go it's the entire thing
is functioning on that wavelength as
opposed to you know trying to be
something else but also at the same time
going look how much or we are mature you
know big air quotes so while that
annoyed me a little bit it's not too bad
but that's really kind of the own that
end and Vandal Savage and kind of being
over him as a character really kind of
the only complaints that I have other
than personal preference on things like
this is not my preferred version of
Waller but it's still good and Vanessa
Williams does good work it's it's uh oh
there's one other thing this was
actually quite cool so I mentioned that
it's not in continuity with assault on
Arkham which was the last time you saw a
Suicide Squad in these films it is
however a direct sequel to an existing
DC animated film and one of the good
ones I might add and I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna spoil it I'm not gonna say
what it is but that was cool that was
actually really cool to to realize what
this is in fact a stealthy direct sequel
to
and the way that they integrated into
the previous film that is connected to
what's actually really good and really
solid that was that's that is the kind
of continuity work that I would like to
see more of where there's not a big push
ahead of time in terms of look how we
are interconnecting our universe like no
no here's this thing like the story
let's because the story works and of
itself even if you haven't seen the
other film that this is connected to but
if you have that's the that is the best
feeling for geeks who get into
continuity because you go oh it's this
little thing that if you catch it it
makes you just feel it just makes you
feel warm inside and that's nice
especially because so many franchises
are doing continuity very badly and in a
way that makes it feel like homework as
opposed to a treat that was a treat here
so I love that and I think I'll wrap it
up there this was a lot of fun so I I'm
not gonna hold my breath that it's the
start of a new streak for the DC
animated because I mean they don't they
can't keep at a level these days but
it's always nice to get a new good entry
from from DC animation and the animation
quality overall seemed better as well it
didn't seem as notably inconsistent as
it can be at time so that was good too I
enjoy it I would recommend it so there
you go Suicide Squad held today have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it this whole bunch of stuff
to do there's buttons and there's links
there's a patreon plus some other stuff
just check out if you feel like it
so just remember folks you are the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]